hey mercedes
was kann ich für dich tun brin nicht zum
messeplatz 1 in essen
[Applaus]
mehr
[Musik]
wir sind hier um mal nachzufragen wie
der neue bußgeldkatalog ankommt dann ist
beschiss
beschiss kostet 400 euro wenn du jetzt
auf dem auf dem fahrradweg parks
es ist
irgendwie schon aber die fahrradfahrer
genau wann hast du es wird ja alles
umgebaut war schon mal in münster
war da nie hin du wirst erschlagen von
fahrradfahrern das ist sogar ein auto
kommen 1000 gefühlt radfahrer der adac
hat den betrieb katalog kassiert sie in
der petition bei vorher hätte man am 21
stundenkilometer zu schnell sein sohn
abgeben star-regisseur genau können sie
sich jetzt gedanken
machen wie man das konzept beim adac ist
so ein bisschen wie beim esc keine
punkte für deutsche aber ganz ehrlich
sagen wenn man das mit anderen ländern
vergleicht sind die strafen nicht allzu
hoch auf das stimmt ich in österreich
zum beispiel beschlagnahme gerne
komplette karte wenn du dich erwischen
wird zu schnell italien würden die ja
versteigert sogar wenn es nicht zahlen
kannst ja gut dass die mafia
tuning ist ein faszinierendes hobby man
kann ein auto komplett verändern aber es
gibt auch menschen die es übertreiben
dass wir zum beispiel waren einen opel
corsa
[Musik]
porsche ist davon an die steuer
persönliches von hat oder wie läuft das
nein das denke ich nicht das ist ein
sponsoring über das
bundesverkehrsministerium sowohl
behörden als auch unternehmen können
dann mal präsentieren das tuning auch
sicher sein kann deswegen polizei look
und eingetütet war zurück können sie
dann gut drin sitzen da kann ich sehr
gut und setzte nur leider nicht mit
waffe aber
es wollte uns wenn ich jetzt sozusagen
auf der straße schneller bin als sie ja
da habe ich ja eigentlich gewonnen wieso
muss ich dann strafe zahlen
man könnte ja denken die polizei fand
juni messe das ist so ein bisschen wie
veganer auf dem grill am netz sein kann
auch anstrengend werden will ich nicht
sagen der vegane auf dem grill haben das
nervig aber die polizei auf ermessen
auch nur irgendwas die sinnvoll ich
wollte mich eigentlich auch kurz
entschuldigen ich habe mein hasen
überfahren
lieber mehr zahlen oder mehr punkte also
ich persönlich würde lieber mehr zahlen
und weniger punkte weil wenn ich ohne
führer bin kann ich meinen job
dranhängen und dann kann das den euro
nicht mehr bezahlten job ich mache
projekt entwicklung wie viel ps hat ein
auto 650
ist gut gegen falten
wie ist noch lang mit geschwindigkeit
was das limit
das dürft ihr fahren auf der autobahn
ohne
[Gelächter]
yao lifa zieht die messe steht unter 3
gg tuned geblitzt gezahlt und untreue
ich gehe jetzt endlich tiefer
hallo leute ich bin der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß
und 70 - wollt dann abonniert jetzt den
kanal
was zur hölle ist - der stelle